Hello,
I manager Moody and this has big ideas
and this is a stereogram.
You've probably seen these before.
It's a computer generated picture that
presents a three dimensional image.
If you're able to focus your eyes just
at the right point,
it takes a while to get the hang of it.
You have to sort of relax and try to
focus just behind the picture and then
slowly a three dimensional image begins
to form,
but it doesn't always work and sometimes
you're left wondering if the three d
image is really there at all.
And according to Jordan Peterson,
a psychologist who teaches at the
University of Toronto stereograms are
analogous to the way that we experience
reality.
Music is another.
It is also composed of patterns and
because music cannot be reduced to
words,
it conveys a world of meaning beyond
reason.
Peterson is a psychologist with a
philosophical bend.
He is interested in how we perceive of
things and what we get from it and he
takes us on a tour to force through
music and computers.
Painting and chess get ready for a heady
and complex ride.
Music is a genuine mystery.
Music is one of the experiential
phenomena that we all have access to.
It's like looking into the night sky or
at the Grand Canyon.
There's something about it that seems to
speak about things that are beyond the
mundane,
and it's an interesting thing that music
can do that because although it has this
arguably transcendental element,
it's also something that's very
accessible to people in general.
It's very rare to find someone who
doesn't like music,
so it's transcendental and universal.
At the same time.
It also seems to me that music
okay
reliably speaks to people of meaning and
that there are,
and that the reason that music plays
such a popular or powerful role in our
culture is because the meaning that
music speaks of is beyond rational
critique and were very rational and were
very intelligent.
And so we've been able to make
intellectual hash out of most of the
things that had traditionally offered
people a grounded sense of meaning.
But because music is beyond rational
criticism,
it seems to have been able to retain its
experiential connection with
transcendent meaning despite the fact
that our rational mind has destroyed
almost everything else.
It's transcendental and part of the
reason I think music can do this is
precisely because it is beyond either
verbal formulation or verbal criticism.
So if you listen to a song,
whether it has lyrics or not,
could perhaps assume that it doesn't.
It does something to you.
And if someone who had never heard music
asked you what it did,
you couldn't tell them in any way that
was a reasonable summary of the
experience itself.
I suppose you could consider that
analogous to trying to describe color to
someone who's blind.
Whatever music is about isn't
translatable into language.
Now we can use language to augment our
pleasure in music.
We do that with lyrics constantly,
but
whatever it is that music speaks of,
if it speaks of something,
is not something you can speak of in
words.
Now,
as rational people,
we're also inclined to presume that if
it's real,
you can speak about it in words,
but there've been culture since the dawn
of history believed that there were
certain things that were not only
unspeakable from a verbal perspective,
but whose meaning was actually
demolished.
If it was put in words.
For example,
in ancient Hebrew societies and
incurrent Islam societies,
it's
heretical,
improper to make an image of the
transcendent and the reason for that,
it's not merely an arbitrary moral law.
Nonsensical from a rational perspective.
The reason for that is is
some things lose their meaning as soon
as they're translated into something
that's as tiny as a word and music is
one of those things,
and I made this little painting here,
it's about seven feet across actually
when I was a graduate student about 20
years ago trying to figure out what
meaning meant and I designed the
painting.
I'll show you a bigger picture of it
later to be something that would kind of
move when you looked at it.
If you make a geometrical figure that
sufficiently complex,
then when your brain looks out at it
tries on different fits and it looks to
your visual perception system as if it's
moving a necker cube,
but reversing cube as a simple example
of that.
I want it to make something here that
moved and danced visually like a,
like a piece of music moves and dances.
That seems to intimate something beyond
itself.
It's hard to do that with a static
sculpture.
It's hard to do that with visual arts in
general.
We do seem to approach it to some degree
with a dance and dance is another art
form that speaks of things that are
beyond words.
That doesn't mean that dance is about
nothing.
It just means that it's about something
that can't be easily put into words.
Now I actually think you can understand
what music means,
but there's a real problem in doing it.
And the problem in understanding what
music means is that it's only sample if
you change the way you look,
almost everything.
The funny thing is is that music speaks
to you of meaning,
whether you understand it or not,
and that's one of the reasons it's an
imperishable art.
I think what music speaks to you,
I was real.
In fact,
I think it's more real than anything
else,
but I would also say that's not normally
how people think.
Okay,
so that's the first part of the spiel.
So I want to tell you some interesting
things about perception.
Now,
here's this problem that's come up in
the last quarter of the 20th century
that was
okay,
formally described by Daniel Dennett
among others.
It's been something that's been plaguing
people who've been attempting to design
machines that can actually operate in
the real world.
Early artificial intelligence
researchers were pretty optimistic about
billing things like general purpose
robots because they believe that
a robot could,
while they believed fundamentally that
the world laid itself out in easily
accessible objects and that those
objects had some,
some reality beyond their perceptual
apparent appearance and that the problem
with developing a machine that could
operate in the real world was only
determining how it should act,
but it turns out that wasn't right.
It turns out that it's very,
very hard to make a machine that can
perceive,
in fact,
it's so hard that it,
it seems technically impossible and that
strange because we can perceive,
but the problem we saw while we proceed
is so complex that in some ways it
appears it on computable,
which is why,
by the way,
one of the reasons we don't have general
purpose robots.
It's also why we don't have computers
that can accurately translate speech.
You know,
you're supposed to be able to talk to
your computer.
People would be promising that for 30
years,
but you can't talk to your computer
because a computer can't understand what
you're saying.
And the reason for that is it turns out
it's a very difficult to listen to what
someone's saying.
And that's partly because all of the
information is not encoded in the sounds
that they're making.
So for example,
part of the reason you can understand
what I'm saying is that you know,
more or less that this is an s or a
lecture about psychology.
You know,
it has a scientific basis.
You know that there are certain things
are not going to talk about.
The entire context within which you sit
informs your understanding of my speech.
And every word I say helps build a
framework for you that informed your
ability to understand each word computer
just can't do that.
Well,
Janet called this the frame problem and
the frame problem was put in a very
simple way by Medina and Nick Wheeler in
the Mit Encyclopedia of cognitive
science.
Medina Nagler pointed out that you can
categorize a relatively small finite
number of objects in virtually an
infinite number of way waves.
And you might think,
well,
what does that have to do with looking
at the world?
And the answer to that is,
well,
perception is a form of categorization.
When you look at something,
you know what that thing is,
your visual system is doing a kind of
classification.
But it turns out that there's a very
large number of ways to look at things.
So for example,
right now I'm looking at you as if
you're an audience full of people.
But if I was an impressionist painter,
I could be looking at you as if you were
surfaces from which certain colored
lights were reflecting.
And you might think that that I suppose
in some way is obvious.
But it's useful to remember that when
the impressionists had their first shows
in Paris basing their artistic
production on this transformation of
perception,
they caused riots.
All right?
So perception is a very difficult
process and artists actually teach us
how to see.
And I don't mean that in again,
I don't mean that in some impractical
way.
I mean that the way we use our eyes is,
has been informed from for hundreds of
thousands of years,
perhaps by the experts among us who were
able to use their visual systems better
than anyone else and who could
communicate that.
It's hard to see the world.
While you can think of that,
if you're playing chess,
you know,
we had to build big computers to beat
Grand Masters at chess and they can
barely do it.
And that's all they can do,
right?
Big Blue plays chess,
but it can't walk down the street and
it's not good at riding a bicycle.
So one purpose machine and the way it
plays chess isn't the way that people
play chess.
It plays chess by doing a reasonably
exhaustive search of every single
combination.
And on a chess board,
there's an unbelievably large number of
potential combinations of moves.
It's immense.
And a chess game is a rather bounded
world and all things considered,
there's a finite number of men.
They have finite rules,
but nonetheless,
it's an unbelievably complex,
uh,
environment in terms of its space of
possibilities.
Expert chess players appear to identify
configurations of men that have some
relevance.
So what they're able to do is to look at
the board and rapidly determine what
they should pay attention to and what
they shouldn't pay attention to.
And they develop that skill by
practicing over thousands of games and
studying chess games and so forth and so
on.
We don't duplicate that with a computer.
And so what you could say is that an
expert chess player is an expert at
being able to see a chest board and they
see extremely well.
And then once they've seen,
they can kind of put constraints around
the cognitive complexity of the problem
and operate within that.
While you guys are doing that all the
time when you look at the world,
but there's so much of your brain
devoted to it.
And you're so bloody good at it that you
don't even know what's happening.
And when you look at the world it's like
there it is and that's all objective and
obvious and there's the objects and you
know they have nothing to do with your
perception,
but it is absolutely not that clear and
it's not clear for a lot of reasons.
I mean one is the frame problem.
The other is that it turns out that when
you look at the world,
you don't see objects and then think
about them and then figure out how to
act.
Your eyes map on all sorts of parts of
your body.
So for example,
the,
your retinas map right onto your spinal
cord and that means your eyes can make
your body move without eat with you,
without you thinking.
And without you seeing.
That's a pretty weird thing.
It's hard to understand it until you
understand that what your retina is
doing is picking up patterns cause it's
like a matrix,
right?
It's like a TV screen.
It picks up patterns from outside world
and then it translates them into
patterns of motor output.
There's no intermediation of perception
whatsoever.
If you're moving very quickly and there
can't be because it takes you too long
to see anything to be fast.
That's why by the way,
when you drive down the road in your
car,
you don't look right in front of the
hood.
That's what good is that if you see it
in front of the hood,
you've already run over it.
You have to look like half a second down
the road because anything that happens
to you closer than that,
it's already too late.
So you look far enough down the road so
that you can get your body to do what
you wanted to do and take into account
how long it takes you to see the world,
which may be up to half a second.
I mean that's one estimate.
I think that's too long,
but that's the standard estimate app at
the time for half a second to long time,
you go 40 feet in a car going 60 miles
an hour and half a second.
The point I'm making there is that when
you see the object,
the seeing produces the action.
So,
for example,
you have a little mechanism and your
motor system that allows you to grab
things and you practice the hell out of
that when you were two years old,
right?
You're just grabbing things left,
right and center til you got the grip
motion down to an automated state.
Well,
if you look at a cup,
the act of looking at the cuff reduces
the threshold for activation of the grip
mechanism.
And that doesn't because you see the cup
and then you think,
I'll pick it up.
It happens as a consequence of seeing
it.
And it turns out that when you're
looking at the world,
you don't see objects exactly what you
see is things that it's useful to
interact with.
And those things are more like tools.
And so I would say,
well you're looking in this room and
what you see are things to interact with
and you think those are objective
objects,
but they're really not.
Or maybe they are.
But there are very,
very,
very tiny subset of all the objects you
could see in this room.
Someone like a schizophrenia whose
perceptions of being somewhat
fragmented.
They have a hard time focusing on the
universal class of usable objects that
everybody looks at.
And so a schizophrenia and sometimes an
artist too can get lost in contemplation
of the complex patterns in the,
in the carpet or the shades of colors
that are in the person's shirt next to
you or all these complex things that you
can see around you,
but that you pay no attention to
whatsoever.
How do you ignore all that?
You ignore almost everything.
99.9 and far more percent of everything
that's around you.
You don't see,
you see relevant things and we really
don't know how you do it.
Uh,
you know already how complex a chest
king,
yes,
now uncomfortable that is yet you're
interacting with an environment who's
complexity leaves a chess game in the
dusk.
You're environment is composed of an,
an infinite number of hierarchically
stacked chess games and yet you wander
through it without a second thought,
unless something goes wrong.
It turns out that perception is the hard
part.
Now,
artists have always known this and you
get modern artists like believe that
some agreed
on the right,
the greed is telling you that the
average person is blinded by their
presuppositions,
right?
That's what that painting needs and the
visual illusion on the left,
which was,
which was constructed by a perceptual
scientist shows that shows how with
knowledge of the visual system you can
play games with it and the game there
is,
well what is that exactly?
Is it an amalgam of lines or is it a
square in the middle of a diamond?
Well,
I would say it's both of those and then
what it is to depends on what it is that
you would do with it.
Well,
you don't do anything with that except
look at it,
but your visual system doesn't know
that.
Okay.
Stu Shah on the left new descending a
staircase.
Well why is that a new descending a
staircase?
While you may be able to see it and you
may not be able to see it.
But what it is is that it's the,
it's the geometric figure of a human
being with the fourth dimension averaged
averaged across the fourth dimension.
Fourth dimension is time.
What you see is the nude transformed
into a geometric figure at each point of
the descent down the staircase.
Now you might say,
well,
that's not a realist painting.
And I would say,
well,
don't be so sure about that.
Abstraction sometimes is more real than
reality,
or do you think that numbers are less
real than things?
While I tell you,
you can do a lot of things with numbers
you can't do with things,
and you could argue that the numbers are
more real than the things.
And I could say,
well,
that's more real than what you see
because you can't see time across
sequences.
You only see it in slices.
And that's across sequences.
And then there's Picasso on the left.
And part of what Picasso was doing,
apart from playing with time and angle,
was trying to determine just how badly
you could mangle and decompose.
Uh,
um,
an iconic image and still be able to
recognize it as an image and it turns
out,
well,
there's not a single thing in that
painting that's reminiscent of a face.
It's the gestalt that does it and you
have a specialized system in your brain.
It's attached to your emotional systems
in an area called the Amygdala that
partly deals with fear.
That is a specialized phase detector
system.
And it's so specialized that if you turn
faces upside down,
it about 60 or 70% of its ability to
discriminate.
It's really specialized.
You look at people in their faces pop
out and you think,
man,
there's so much difference between
phases.
There's not that much difference at all
objectively speaking,
and it's certainly possible for you to
have have a stroke that will leave you
almost entirely intellectually and
perceptually intact and yet be
absolutely unable to tell one face from
another.
Well on the bottom left,
I guess that's a little girl.
Well,
how,
how is it that you can know that?
Well,
it's partly because the castle has
taught you to see things like that,
but also because your visual system is
unbelievably good at producing rapid
abstractions.
Think about it this way.
You know those simple drawings that kids
make of stick figures?
Those aren't simple,
right?
Because a stick figure,
it doesn't look anything like a person.
In fact,
it looks about as unlike the person has
anything possibly could and still be a
person.
The thing that's so interesting about a
kid stick figures,
it gives you insight into the tremendous
ability of them to abstract away from
reality,
right?
And they're really not images at all.
They're like Harold glyphs.
They're quasi linguistic representations
because you know a stick figures the
next best thing to,
to a written symbol kids,
they just generate those nonstop house.
This is a house.
It's got some smoke coming out of it,
right?
You recognize that house in no time,
flat kid,
three years old,
four years old can spin one of those off
in no time flat.
Their perceptual systems are
unbelievably sophisticated and they do
not merely map self evidence objects
onto the cognitive system.
Perception doesn't work like that at
all.
It's difficult to overemphasize.
Yeah.
I nude
to people on a beach grief.
Oh,
that's a really interesting one.
Hey,
you can just nail that as grief in no
time flat.
Why?
While the color death,
green and purple,
I don't know what he did with the eyes.
Why it manages.
It's a wellness appears like a tour,
I think,
and this of course,
it's a handkerchief.
It's a striking image and so mangled
that it's almost beyond recognition.
Nonetheless.
You can categorize it from an emotional
perspective and no time flat.
What's that?
To delve nation.
There's the head.
Do you see it?
There's the leg,
here's the leg.
There's the back of it.
Does everybody see the Dalmatian?
How many people see it?
It's there,
right?
How many people don't see it?
Well,
is it there or not?
Call her head shadow leaves background
sidewalk.
Once you get it,
you can't not see it if you don't get
it.
If you don't grip it as it gets stalled.
What is it?
Random patterns.
While they're not random,
but that's only because you had,
you're familiar with dogs and living
things.
That's as of a random pattern is
anything you could generate deceptive.
It also happens to be a dog.
How do we see things?
And that's a really good question.
It's really hard to answer.
Partly we limit our vision,
we see through a lens,
it's hard to describe what this lens is.
It's,
it's the lens that allows us to use our
intuitions about a situation to specify
the meaning of the current moment.
So imagine you're reading a book and
then you think,
well how do you read that book?
Exactly.
You read it letter by letter,
what little kids do,
but they don't like to read.
And that's because they have to read
letter by letter.
You read a book,
letter by letter and see how much
enjoyment you get out of it,
right?
So you get the letters automated,
you build a little machine in the back
of your mind that nails those letters
and then common combinations.
And then you can read word by word and
then you automate that with several
thousand hours of practice until you're
so good at that.
When you look at a word you can't help
but read.
It just goes off in your head like the
word is in the outside world.
Then if you keep practicing,
you see phrases and if you're really
good you start to see sentences.
But you get pretty speedy at that point.
Okay,
so then the question is when you're
reading a book,
do you read it phrase by phrase or
sentence by sentence and sentence?
And the answer to that is,
well no,
not exactly.
You read it,
you read the word,
you read the phrase,
you read the sentence,
you read the paragraph,
you read the chapter,
you read the book,
you know the cover,
you know the culture,
you know the intent of the author.
And all of those things are going on
simultaneously while you're trying to
extract meaning out of that book.
So it's as if you're looking at the word
through a lens made up of the success of
layers of knowledge that you have that
allow you to zero in on the meaning of
what it is that the author is attempting
to explain.
And then you think,
well,
what does,
so think about how someone translates.
You can't do it word by word.
He can't do it phrase by phrase it
letter by letter,
we'll just forget it and you can't get a
computer to translate.
Why?
Well it's because when you read
something,
you figure out what it means and then
you translate it so that it also means
that the next language,
so it's as if the verbal,
the verbal level,
verbal portrayal is one motive,
reality perception,
but it translates onto another mode and
that mode is meaning and then it can be
back translated into another lane.
And that's how a good translator does
it.
And that's also white translation is an
art,
right?
I mean,
did you get the meaning?
Right?
Well who knows if it's a philosopher,
I mean philosophers mean a lot of
different things.
At the same time.
Question is what's the level of reality
down at which to you translate the
words?
Well,
it seems to have something to do with
movement and action and behavioral
output.
It seems to have something to do with
the fact that we have a body.
It isn't a merely intellectual exercise
because when you read something and it
has meaning,
you think,
I know what that means and what that
means is having read this,
I know how to do something differently,
or I know how to conceptualize something
differently so that my actions will be
different in the future.
That's why we generally say if it's
fiction,
say that it has a moral right.
There's a behavioral consequence.
There's a,
that's what the meaning of the story is.
That's the point.
You know,
we can get the point.
That means that while you either do
something differently or you perceive
and then act generally differently,
and if it's really meaningful,
you say,
well,
that changed my life.
Or what does that mean?
I no longer see things the same way.
That's as close to literal truth as you
lead,
you know,
I no longer think the same.
Things are important.
Well,
it's important things to which you
devote your action and if the thing is
powerfully meaningful,
then it transforms the manner in which
you act and the aims towards which you
act.
That's meaningful.
Now our lens has help us specify
meaning,
well,
you know your lenses give you all sorts
of different takes on the world and you
might think,
well are those takes real?
And I would say,
well,
here's the odd thing.
They are real,
but any visual landscape is so complex
that you can derive a very large number
of real representations up.
So I could say,
well,
here's a low resolution photograph real.
Is it more or less real than a high
resolution photograph?
What if it's black and white?
Is that less or more real than color?
What if it's three dimensional instead
of two dementia?
What if it's abstracted,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
You can imagine how many photographs of
a single object you could conceivably
take.
They're all slices of what that thing is
or their representational slices of our
conceptions of what it is and they're
all valid.
There's a large number of valid
interpretations.
You know,
it's a funny thing because the
humanities ran into the frame problem.
Hey,
the humanities run into their frame
problem with postmodernism because the
postmodern is starting to become aware
of the fact that if you took a book,
there was no end to the number of
interpretations you could derive from
it.
And so the postmodern start,
well then anything goes.
No techs have any intrinsic meaning.
Well,
I don't think that's true for a variety
of reasons,
but it was certainly,
uh,
appropriate inference given what they
had discovered.
If you can't specify the meaning of a
text,
how can you be sure that it has any
meaning at all?
Very hard question.
Well,
it turns out that at least in part,
meaning is dependent on the Lens.
So we can imagine this,
imagine that this is what the world's
like.
It's an infinite hierarchical landscape,
not about objects but of patterns.
And some of those patterns are objects,
patterns that persist,
for example,
or patterns that persists that are
useful.
So if I to you will,
what's a chair?
And you say,
well,
a chair has four legs and a seat and a
back.
And I say,
well,
no,
a stump doesn't have any of those and
neither does a bean bag,
but they're both chairs.
And so then you say,
well,
it's a chair.
If you can sit on it.
And I say,
well you can sit on a table and it turns
out the defining what a chair is,
no easy thing.
Even though you know one,
when you see one,
well imagine this,
the world's made out of patterns.
And those patterns can be interpreted in
a very large number of ways.
But it's more complicated than that
because your mind is made up of patterns
too.
And when you take your mind in the
patterns that are in your mind and you
apply them to the world than what you
get is an interaction between the
patterns that the world are made out of
is made out of,
and the patterns that your mind are made
out of.
And that's an even more complex pattern.
And it has something to do with reality
as such.
But it also has something to do with
you.
And then I would say,
well the reality is actually in the
interaction between the two sets of
patterns.
And I don't mean that metaphysically.
I mean the reality is in the
interactions between the two sets of
patterns.
And so when I said if you want to
understand what music means,
you have to change the way that you
think about things.
What I mean is that what music speaks of
is a way of understanding reality that
is not like the way we understand
reality and yet it's a way,
it's a way that even when merely
intimated,
which is what music does,
it grips people powerfully at in a way
that cannot be irrationally criticized.
Unless you say that the meaning that
music speaks of is not real well then I
would say it depends on your definition
of reality and you know there's lots of
ways to play that game.
You know,
you can define thing a or thing B as
real or out of reality in a variety of
different ways.
Well you have to make choices about what
you decided is real.
Right.
That's why philosophers since time in
memorial have pointed out that like it
or not,
your existence is grounded in faith.
Now what's your lens like?
I can tell you what my lens is like.
Imagine I'm writing a paper,
which I do fairly often.
Um,
why do I write the paper?
Well,
let's make it simpler.
Why do I write the sentence while I
write the sentence to contribute to the
paragraph and I read the paragraph to
contribute to the essay and I write the
essay to contribute to the paper and I
write the paper because it's part of
being a scientist and I am a scientist
because it's part of being a professor
and I'm a professor because it's part of
least in principle,
being a good citizen and being a good
citizen has a definition in a,
in a Judeo Christian capitalist society,
being a good citizen is being a Judeo
Christian capitalist for better,
for worse.
Hey,
and so when I'm,
even when I'm engaged in something as
potentially trivial is writing a single
sentence in an essay,
all of those sources of knowledge bear
on it simultaneously.
And that's what helps me specify its
meaning.
And you can't say that any one of those
levels of analysis is more real than any
other.
Now you can say it's more pragmatically
worthwhile to focus on a certain level
at a certain point in time.
But I'll tell you if I,
if I get a paper that's rejected badly
enough,
which happens fairly often,
I don't start thinking,
well,
the sentence was wrong.
I started thinking I'm a pretty awful
scientist and therefore I must not be a
very good professor.
And that puts the whole productive
science citizen thing in doubt.
And you think hard about that for a bit.
And you'll understand real quick why
people don't like other people who mess
around with their presuppositions,
right?
Because it goes pretty quickly up the
old reality hierarchy from you have a
stupid idea to your,
you know,
your,
your moral grip on your privileged
position is,
uh,
unjustifiable.
Well,
let's take a simple lent.
Okay?
How do you look at the world while
you're a motivated creature and you're
alive and you're always doing something
fiddling around with something.
You know when in the old Mesopotamian
creation myths that God is who lived
underneath everything.
She'd always come up in a terribly
destructive rourke as people were
running around on the planet doing
things in disturbing here.
While we still believe that,
right?
Because we believe if we mess around
with the environment long enough,
so all hell's gonna break clicks,
but you know,
we're always running around messing
things up.
That's what we do,
right?
We're going from point a to point B and
you know how it is.
You have a goal,
you pursue it,
get the goal.
As soon as you get the goal,
you have another goal and you pursue
that.
As you get that,
it says if this roll the rock up the
hill,
rolls down the hill,
roll it up,
the hill was down the hill,
eventually get tired of that and you
die.
You're stuck in one of these,
hey,
and it gives your life value because it
turns out that the way your emotional
systems work is that they only worked if
you have a goal.
So you have a goal,
whatever that is,
and then anything that happens to you
that puts you closer to the goal,
that makes you happy and it turns on
your systems that make you go ahead,
move forward,
be attracted to anything that gets in
the way of your goal.
Depending on its
potency,
produces negative emotion,
anxiety,
frustration,
disappointment,
shame,
guilt,
anger stops you or makes you move
backwards.
You're a pretty simple creature in some
ways,
you're going somewhere.
If things are going well,
you're happy because happy means things
are going well in progression to a goal.
And if they aren't,
you're not happy.
Forward.
Stop.
Reverse forward is happy.
Stopped is anxious,
reverses,
frustration,
disappointment,
pain.
We're linear creatures and we're always
on the move and we look at the world
through a motivated led's,
right?
This isn't secondary.
It's not after perception.
It informs perception,
which means really that you can't look
at the world without wanting something.
And which also means that the way the
world looks to you depends what you
want.
That's a scary thought.
What you see when you're looking at the
world,
well,
you see,
they're not objects they've been called
affordances.
You see things that have relevance to
you.
Well,
I think it has to persist a bit for it
to be relevant to you.
So a lot of the things that we see our
objects,
but not everything.
There's one,
here's an ad hoc category.
Firemen can see this,
but other people can't.
Things to take out of your apartment
while it's burning down.
Okay?
Now that's a category,
right?
You can even imagine that as a
perceptual category,
but the thing is that it contains share
virtually no objective features,
pets,
spouses,
probably
things of sentimental value money.
Well then maybe the list gets more
difficult to define,
but you understand,
you'll see that the goal there,
which is to get out of the apartment
before you die with some things of value
to what you see and you may object.
I wouldn't actually see that.
And I would say,
Oh yeah,
you would.
If you're looking at a bowl of fruit and
it has three bananas and two apples in
an orange unit.
And I asked you what that is and you say
it's a bowl of fruit.
Why you see his fruit,
not two apples and whatever.
I mentioned two bananas,
two apples and the peach.
You see fruit,
you see what you categorize or
opposite.
You categorize when you see she moving
along from where you are to where you
want to go.
And you parse the world up into useful
things that get you to where you want to
go.
And knowing things that don't.
And if everything works out fine while
you get here,
then you have a new one.
If he's
but there's a catch.
Now here's the catch.
When you look at the world,
you hardly see anything that's there.
You know you're simplifying things,
but everything that you don't see is
still there.
So imagine that you're inhabiting this
little sort of simplified and somewhat
perfected domain all the time.
It's wandering around you.
It's,
it's,
it's part of what you inhabit.
But the real world,
whatever that is,
is out there.
I've often thought about the story of in
Genesis,
you know the story of Adam and eve in
that regard,
because what you have there is a kind of
paradise where everything's really going
well.
And you know,
you've all lived in a pair of dice like
that when things were going really well,
right?
But there's always snakes in those
paradises.
And the reason for that is just because
things are going well,
it doesn't mean you've accounted for
everything and you can't account for
everything.
So there's always something lurking
around from underneath.
And if you go and mess with thing,
then all hell breaks loose and you
think,
well,
has that ever happened to you?
Well,
sure happens to you.
If you have a relationship and the
person you're having a relationship with
cheats on you,
that's a snake for sure.
It happens to you.
If you're well and then you're not,
it happens to you if you're dependent on
a family member and they'd die,
right?
It's the unrevealed complexity of the
world that manifests itself.
Suddenly that wreaks havoc on our little
paradises.
Well,
and we're so damn curious,
hey,
we just can't leave well enough alone.
That's human beings for sure,
right?
Just like the Catholics say,
heritable sit,
right?
You put people into paradise and you
tell them not to do one thing and you
can bloody well be sugar.
That's the first thing they're going to
do because we're so curious.
We cannot leave things a little.
We're always unraveling sweaters and
looking at things we're not supposed to
look at.
So on and so forth.
And you know,
it's a great thing and we learned a lot,
but we pay a big price for it.
The question is
what do you look at when you don't know
what you see?
What is it that you see when you don't
know what you see?
So think about it this way.
This is a very,
very hard thing to understand.
Remember when the towers fell?
What did you see?
Why you say,
well,
I saw the towers fall and I said,
no,
no.
If all you saw was that the towers fell,
you wouldn't have looked at it.
50 types.
Why did you have to look at it 50 times
or cause you couldn't believe it?
What did that mean?
It meant that the event was so complex
that you couldn't perceive it.
What fell?
Uh,
the monetary system in the u s the
Western economy,
it was the transformation of the Cold
War,
uh,
was a new paradigm.
Um,
it was a battle between good and evil
that popped up pretty quick.
Like the next day,
pretty much.
You had to look at it over and over and
over and over because he didn't know
what you were seeing.
He didn't know how to see what you were
seeing and you think,
okay,
I don't quite get that.
And then I would think,
okay,
when you're driving your car and it
breaks down,
what is it?
When it breaks down?
And you might say it's a car.
And I would say if you persist on
thinking that that thing that isn't
moving as a car,
you're going to have nothing but
frustration because what it is now is a
very complex assemblage of parts you
don't understand.
One of which is key to transforming it
back into a car.
And so what happens is that it reveals
itself suddenly as a consequence of its
noncompliance with your wishes as the
complex structured entity that it
actually is.
You have to go pay a mechanic because
the mechanic knows the magic sequence
that will turn this intransigent bit of
complex junk back into the simple thing
that you can drive to work well and
you'll pay for that,
right?
Because it's valuable because for you to
get that thing back to being in a car
and take you maybe 10 years,
cause what do you know near Bro Likely
to make it worse than mechanical.
Just still tap and you'll say,
well you've charged me $500 for that.
And he'll say,
well,
it's a savings for you,
right?
You don't know where to tap.
So long trip,
okay,
what do you see when you don't know what
to seek?
That's what I think music is about.
Now I'll tell you why.
So what music does think of Bach?
Then what he does is he takes this
temporal span and then he builds these
complex patterns across it,
right?
And some of the patterns like,
and some of them go like this and some
of them go like this and there's a
pattern here in a pattern here,
in a pattern here and pattern there.
And some of them are going backwards.
I mean the guy's complicated,
you know?
Um,
it's stunning actually.
He actually wrote a song that you can
play upside down and backwards and it's
the same song,
man.
It's unbelievable.
Bach wrote so much music that it would
take a talented copyist,
someone who just copies music 40 years
of eight hour days just to transcribe
it.
Anyways,
Bach,
he presents you with this landscape.
It's an abstracted landscape of what the
landscape says is look at all the cool
patterns.
There's just layers and layers of them.
And then he,
he asks your perceptual system,
it says here,
focus on this one.
There's this little interesting thing
happening.
It's partly patterned and predictable,
but not too much.
Cause then it's like a computer road.
It's patterned and predictable,
but it has this little edge of novelty
on it.
And that's,
that's interesting.
That novelty keeps you dripped and you
can pick out the patterns.
It's as if you're turning them into
auditory objects on with Bach,
you can do that at 10 levels at the same
time.
It's an an analog,
it's an analog of the real world and you
get that as soon as you stopped thinking
of the real world as a simple place of
objects,
it's not,
it's a complex place of patterns and
those patterns shift and change with
different in different situations and
with different temporal frames of
reference.
And that's what music is telling you and
that's why it's so deeply meaningful.
Cause Music says to you here,
this is actually the structure of the
world beyond your simple perceptions.
This is the structure of the world.
Well that's kind of what I figured out
when I was making this thing,
why I wanted it to kind of rotate a bit.
I don't know if it's successful.
It's actually a cube that said on edge.
So that's the edge of the cute there.
And so you can see into the cube.
It's a spiral at the same time and then
it's a tunnel.
It's imagine a tunnel that's going back
to a point and it's fragmented into
these four things here.
And so it's like things are bursting out
of the middle of this tunnel and that
that's what music is like,
right?
There's this just constant onslaught of
new complex pattern forms.
I thought,
what does that mean?
It means something.
Listen to music things.
This means something.
I can feel it like I can experience it
and I say,
well,
if you experience it,
it's real.
How will you might think,
well,
the meaning of music isn't real.
Well,
it depends on what you mean,
right?
It depends on your presuppositions.
I think what means things is real.
There's this old idea,
you know,
this is a funny little turn of phrase,
but I like it.
Materialists,
they think the world's made out of
matter,
right?
Well,
this perspective isn't predicated on
that idea.
This perspective is predicated on the
idea that reality is made out of what
matters and music expresses what
matters.
Well,
and then you think,
well,
is there any reason to think that way?
Well,
and I would say,
well,
soldier Nansen he said it's taking a
page from Dostoyevsky said beauty will
save the world.
So funny thing a,
because Solzhenitsyn is actually one of
the people who helped save the world
because his truth was at least in part,
responsible for knocking out material in
the Soviet Union.
You know,
so maybe he's someone worth listening
to.
Well,
what's meaning worth?
if you listen to music,
you know,
you can experience what music does to
you.
It's direct,
it's in your own experiential field.
The problem is you can't exactly
quantify or qualify it by referring to
other people cause it's a personal
experience.
But just because it's a personal
experience doesn't mean it isn't real
pains real or isn't it by Italia.
If you're in enough pain,
you're not going to be rationally
arguing about that point.
You know,
we have an idea in our culture that it's
what we know that saves us in a way.
You know,
that that keeps us able to cope with all
of the pressures of being alive.
And that's true.
You know,
what we do is very,
very useful,
but it's not useful enough because no
matter how much you know,
there are certain problems that you
still have and they're,
they're eternal problems.
There are the problems that you're
fragile and all sorts of ways,
mentally fragile,
physically fragile,
emotionally fragile,
you know,
you're not as good looking as you might
be,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And no matter how much you know,
none of that's really going to change.
And so you find cold comfort in
knowledge and I'm not putting down
knowledge.
Knowledge is a great thing,
but it's not enough.
And so then you think,
well,
what do you have except what you know?
And then I would say you have what you
don't know.
And there's a lot of that,
right?
You're never going to run out of what
you don't know.
And then I would say,
well then maybe what makes the
difference between having a life that is
acceptable and and appropriate and one
that's resentful and,
and full of hatred is what sort of real
relationship you establish with what it
is that you don't know.
There's always more to learn.
And you see in in fairy tales and
religious mythology,
people are always exhorted to be humble.
It's very annoying thing to be,
I would say.
But there's a funny,
there's a twist on that.
It's a,
it's a very interesting notion because
the humble person isn't exactly meek.
The humble person is someone who knows
that the expanse of what they don't know
supersedes the expanse of what they do
know.
And so that it's in the encounter with
what's not known,
that all the real information,
that's where all the action takes place.
And you kind of know that a,
because when you're really interested in
something and it grips you,
you know,
you're right on the edge of where all
the information is coming,
right?
That's what makes it exciting.
You know something,
but you're on the trail or something you
don't know,
and that really grips you and it should
grip you because that's where you're
getting all the new information.
And I think what music does as far as
I'm concerned,
is it speaks to us about what we don't
know.
It says,
look,
there's outside of our presuppositions,
there's this domain that that is
constantly patterned and informative and
meaningful and if you're open to it in
the appropriate way,
which is to pay attention to the
limitations of your knowledge and to
watch what you're doing and more than a
merely intellectual sense that this
unknown pattern,
expats is richly informative events
sustain it.
And I think that every time you listen
to a piece of music and it grabs you,
that's what it's telling you.
And I also think you know that now you
don't know what to say it,
but there's lots of things you don't
know to say.
You don't know how to keep your heart
beating.
You don't know how to walk.
I mean the list of things you don't know
is a very long list.
And the mere fact that you don't know it
doesn't mean that it isn't true.
Well then you ask yourself with regards
to your relationship with something like
music is what it says real or not.
And I would say like pain.
What music tells you is so real that it
makes other things that are real seem to
pale in comparison.
Well you know I like music a lot so
maybe that's an experience that it's
idiosyncratic to me.
But then you have to explain I suppose
why music has had such a powerful grip
on our culture or it's funny cause I
read a book on evolutionary psychology
while ago written by Steven Pinker,
a big thick book.
It was like one little thin chapter at
the end devoted to aesthetics,
music and religion.
And I thought that's pretty interesting.
You know,
because for some people like aesthetics,
religion,
well let's say philosophy is like this
much of the book with the rest of it
being this much and
our mind,
I'm not really interested in debating
that.
What I am interested more in saying is
that
there is a way to understand what it is
that our aesthetic experiences tell us.
But what they tell us isn't in the
language that we normally speak and the
language that aesthetics toxin has
something genuine to offer us.
It's not HEPA.
Phenomenal.
It's not derivative.
It's not secondary.
It's fundamental and primary.
It's about what things mean and how to
act.
And for us that's a big deal because we
need to know how to act and the arts
tell us that.
And music tells us that in the most sort
of comprehensive and
the most comprehensive and abstract way,
it's,
it's still grips.
You though.
It grips your body,
even it makes you move.
It's abstract,
but it's,
it's concrete at the same time.
And you can't argue it away.
If you experience it,
you can see exactly what it means.
And I think that when you listen to
music,
what you experience is what you should
experience in relationship to reality.
And I think it's that observation that
does for you what it is that music does
for you.
And all great art does that.
And all great literature.
And I would say there's no reason not to
assume it's real.
That's it.
Oh yes.
Music could be the fruit of love.
Play on according to Peterson,
existence is made up of infinite
hierarchical landscapes of patterns.
And it is only through focusing the lens
of your perception that you actually
make any sense of existence at all the
way,
but you look at the world is guided by
your wants and the way that the world
looks at you.
It depends on what you.